hey guys Justin and I'm talking with
Kelsey here who is the merchandise
coordinator for Square Enix now Square
Enix does more than just Final Fantasy
and those games that are really popular
they actually make toys for a lot of a
lot of different things as we can see
right behind us and Kelsey is going to
talk to us about some of these comic-con
exclusives that some of them are for
sale and some of them are just in the
prototype stage what do we got behind us
right now okay so yeah actually Square
Enix products makes all kinds of great
figures especially Batman figures so
from Batman Arkham origins this is our
San Diego comic-con exclusive it's a
limited color version kind of a metallic
version of our Batman from Arkham
origins so he has like this shiny finish
like he's like standing atop a tower in
the moonlight that's kind of the way
that we like to describe it but also all
of these items that are in here are for
sale at the show and you can see that
the this one up top the DC Comics
variant Batman it's a red color variant
it's actually already sold out but all
of these up top are a DC Comics variants
so basically our Japanese designers took
classic DC Comics characters but their
own spin on them their classics Square
and expen and a beta design and then we
made a figure out of that that concept
and just to be clear we're actually only
halfway through day one it's only
Wednesday how quickly do these things
tend to sell out well it really depends
on how much we'd bring and we don't
bring a lot especially for things that
have been out for a little while so the
red Batman for example it's been out for
a little while so we brought everything
we had left just to give to fans one
more chance to get it so those tend to
go really quickly and then of course
obviously our comic-con exclusive style
like hotcakes but we try and bring
enough so that every fan can get a hold
of one and what have we got in this case
here so this is kind of art like DC
prototype case it gives you an idea of
what's coming up in the coming year from
us with a DC Comics line so up top is
Hawkman and Darkseid this is also our DC
Comics variant Play Arts Kai of course
so Hawkman is really like staggering
figure and we're gonna be sharing more
information about him and Darkseid soon
on our website and our Twitter and I'll
give that information to you guys
shortly and then below them we have
Joker he's being shown here in color in
the US for the first time so it's really
like vivid I pop in color you can see
it's missing grin he has these straight
razors in his
and this is another one of our variants
so this is a completely unique design in
the middle is the armored Batman this is
the first time we're showing this
armored Batman we just love making
Batman figures so much we're always
trying to find new ways to innovate on
the design and then next to him is a
Harley Quinn I know this is a personal
favorite of the designer so I also
really love Harley of course so I'm
really delighted with how she came out
in full color and down here on the
bottom actually we're showing for the
first time our Arkham Knight figures so
from Batman Arkham Knight we have Robin
and then Batman of course so Batman from
Arkham Knight of course compared to
Arkham origins was as more of a prequel
story arkham knight version he kind of
looks more grizzled like more
experienced kind of care worn and then
next to him is Joker this is from Arkham
origins again so yeah we have a more
youthful looking Joker who's just
starting to get up to his deviousness
and next to him is Robin also a version
that appears in Arkham origins as you
can see from the hands and that faces
that are located here these are fully
poseable completely articulate you can
put them kind of in whatever pose you
want them to they're not just like
static statues sitting here play arts
there are a piece of art that you can
play with you can pose it anyway the
only limit is your creativity when it
comes to posing and then this is
actually really exciting reveal that we
have done at comic-con this is a DC
Comics variant Batman that was been
designed by Tetsuya Nomura you may know
him you definitely know him as a
character designer from Final Fantasy
and the creator of Kingdom Hearts so we
kind of went to numerous and we were
like hey we've been doing this crazy DC
Comics variant line would you be
interested in doing Batman and Anna
Morrison was like yeah and of course
being numerous on he really pulled out
all the stops and did this incredible
design for this figure you can see these
wings are all articulated and poseable
there's these sort of bat claws that are
behind Batman and we kind of come up
with a story behind this design that
that Bruce Wayne has died or he's
appeared to have died and now this
Batman has appeared and inside him is
Bruce Wayne sleeping like a walking tomb
and he doesn't fight himself he uses
these claws in these hands to not lay
Joe hands directly on his victims but
fight from afar so that's just something
fun that we're doing and then kind of a
teaser sorry I tend to be long-winded
this is kind of a teaser for another
thing that we're gonna be working on so
no more asan signature is actually right
here on this little placard and you can
see some some cat paws and next written
to it so dot dot what has caps so Robin
cat boys and Batman I think Robin may be
the Joker I love those número designs
like I was so excited when I first saw
that I would actually love to see even
more of something like that like maybe a
movie that that he does the art design
for that would be incredible or a comic
book series okay
oh so these are also some more as our DC
Comics variants I'm sorry guys excuse me
so these are called our Batman timeless
the so this collection actually we came
up with it the crew at square enix
America we kind of came up with this
concept of it's a little bit like a
comic book series where a Batman is
slipping through time but instead of
that it's more like what if there was
always a Batman throughout every era of
history so we have like a cowboy Batman
a wild-west Batman a steampunk Batman
and then a Spartan Batman and a samurai
Bushido Batman very cool and the samurai
Bushido or over here or this the night
when it looks like so um do you see
these are in gray right now that's
because they're still in the prototype
stage so eventually they'll be in full
color fully painted and this is the
first time we're showing them so I know
about as much as you guys do about the
details of this figure so just a really
exciting design I'm really looking
forward to seeing the final products the
finished thing and learning more about
how to get my hands on these so a little
bit of a teaser but exciting to think
about what those are going to mean this
next one though it's a little bit creepy
I obviously Gollum from The Hobbit
what's the story behind this one so we
actually have a line of things called
static arts minis so instead of being a
posable figure it's just a little
statuette and so we have done a DC
Comics a very aesthetic arts mini it
takes our DC Comics variant designs and
shrinks it down to sort of like a large
headed small-bodied cutified version
like chibi five version and we were like
hey let's do that with Gollum too
because it's really
popular especially in Japan and he kind
of has this like creepy cute thing going
on that yeah this is that ik is it's
pretty cool overseas and you know what
I'm actually into it it's kind of like a
pug it's it's kind of creepy and it's
cute I think it could grow on you after
a while this those eyes they stare into
your soul and want to eat you but also
want you to pet it and of course a
classic here from final fantasy 12 yeah
so this is Fran from final fantasy 12
our director of merchandise always
really wanted to do a Fran figure and he
didn't get the chance when 12 first came
out so he's just kind of revisiting Fran
and saying hey I really want to do a
Fran figure so unfortunately it doesn't
really mean that there's gonna be news
about any games but you're definitely
gonna see this beautiful figure this is
the first time we're showing her in full
color and then in North America so I'm
really excited to show off this figure
speaking of things that would lead
people to want to talk about new games
or some Final Fantasy 7 characters here
as well and people love to talk about
bringing that series back of course I
mean it's a classic it's really just
like an iconic game so I understand why
people are so passionate about it but
these designs are from Final Fantasy 7
Advent Children so that was the film
that followed the story after Final
Fantasy 7 so we have Barrett Wallace
here on display and then next to him is
red 13 and we have red 13 in full color
I'm really looking forward to when we
can announce the pricing and the release
dates for these guys but so far no news
and then of course we also have Tifa and
cloud as they appear in Advent Children
so you can see cloud and kind of has the
cloudy wolf motif on his shoulder and
actually what's really cool about this
prototype of cloud is it looks like he's
gonna have poseable fabric as part of
his design so that's a real cloth that
you're seeing there it's not PVC like
the rest of the figure so it has like a
piece of metal in it that'll let you
shift and move it around so that you can
have that be a part of the character as
well yeah absolutely so it adds some
dynamic posing to the character and I
guess closing out we're gonna leave
final fantasy behind again but go into
another very beloved franchise yes
absolutely so we're really excited to
show this off for the first time it's um
this is actually a variant of predator
so again you know we're pretty exciting
to get
really well known for doing our own
original designs and this is another one
of those variant designs so this is a
predator done in our variant design
sorry I've said variant design like five
times but basically he's based on a red
demon from Japanese folklore you may
know him as like Oni or akka Oni so you
can see he kind of has horns he has this
club that's kind of a signature to that
kind of a folkloric character we just
thought it would be cool if like Oh what
if the legends of Oni in Japan were
actually based on predators visiting
earth so that's the concept behind this
figure and another predator right here
yeah so this is just the classic design
of predator we really wanted to make
sure that you know we were appealing to
fans new and old and then kind of giving
something really unique but also just
something that fans would be clamoring
for which is you know classic predator
figure you can almost see the saliva
dripping from his fangs that is that is
scary he comes with a human skull
accessory so that's pretty hardcore cool
and for closing out we have two more
games which are slightly newer and not
necessarily Square Enix titles but scran
excite to partner with these other
developers and create some awesome
sculptures around their games yeah
absolutely we've had a really long and
really successful partnership with
Microsoft and halo so this is we just
really wanted to do another Master Chief
figure and then it really worked out
well for us that the halo Master Chief
collection happened to be announced
around the time that we first displayed
this halo 2 anniversary edition player
sky Master Chief so as you can see he
comes with all of these amazing
accessories and this is the first time
we're showing him in color so get
excited like I always hurt has kind of
the oppose that saying hey I'm here and
the other big one this one's not colored
in yet so it's still a prototype but
some titanfall yeah and this one is
actually already available for pre-order
on our webstore so even though here
we're showing him in grey prototype
right here it's probably just because
he's already been the painted prototype
has already been sent off to China to be
like the the master for a painting so
this gray guy you can get him in
December of this year actually so
order him on our online store you can
also pre-order them through you know
some of our distributors if you're a
mom-and-pop shop and yeah we're just
really excited to show off this
titanfall figure it has an open
articulated hatch so the hatch opens and
closes and actually there's kind of like
a it's hard to describe but that's fear
there where like the camera looks around
it's a it's pivoted so that it can like
move through almost 180 degrees so
that's really cool and he comes with
since it's a symbiotic relationship
between pilot and Titan we did have this
effect piece of the pilot riding the
Titan on top of there but he is not
articulated he's really just for an
effect so he just kind of rides on top
of the Titan and you mentioned that you
can pre-order you can buy some of these
now the San Diego comic-con exclusive
zorak or of course you know exclusive to
comic-con
if you guys don't sell them out though
are you guys gonna put him up on the
store for other people to buy we
actually had a limited pre-order run of
our San Diego comic-con exclusive for
people who couldn't attend the show and
it already sold out it sold out in like
a week and a half so I'm pretty sure
we're gonna sell out during the show but
if if there's some chance that we have
some extra I'm sure we're gonna try and
get it to anybody who maybe was
wait-listed for a pre-order and there's
a lot of other cool stuff as we as we
saw that is gonna be coming out soon
that people will be able to pre-order
the people can buy right now so check
out the square next door